I turn to one of the all-time great
Indianapolis Colts and my friend from
the NFL Network Super Bowl champion
six-time Pro Bowler member of the 2000
yard receiving club I don't show you
should well give me another give me
another shot here all right hold on a
second
one of the all-time great I'm covering
my eyes right now Super Bowl champion
six-time Pro Bowl a member of the 10,000
yard receiving club only wait how was
that that's perfect awesome what do you
think of that decision by Frank Reich of
the Colts I love it
you do I absolutely do I don't I don't
see how guys want to play for ties and
NFL I don't I don't see I mean you you
only got 16 games you practice all heart
you all week you want to go for the win
I can see well how the outsiders can
sell them and say man how do you go for
that but as a player you want to go for
that we want you to put your chips on us
now grant it like that what ey I wasn't
in the game Jack Doyle wasn't any game
correct you know some that if you want
to bring up that aspect did not get it
but as far as me being a former player
or even if I was on that team I would
want you to put your chips on us yeah I
mean I think in retrospect the 20/20
hindsight of it is the the calling the
timeout this would hurt and then coming
out of the timeout I can Houston called
a timeout to burn a timeout exactly and
so had the Colts had the Colts then just
stepped right up there the surprise was
over with right cuz if the culture just
step right up there you thought okay
they're just trying to my god you could
add that exact they call the timeout
themselves you help them you help them
but as far as the play call the play
call wasn't bad it wasn't bad I just
think you got a better shot if that's t
why hild mm-hmm you know when you're
sure handed guys but as a former player
like I want you to I want you to go
forward let's go I mean their office
Texas office was rolling anyway right
now this kind of reminded me back when
we played New England and coach
Belichick went for it on fourth down did
you feel like it couldn't stop him so I
think that
kind of played a little factor in it as
well yeah I remember I remember
Superbowl one team went on side to start
the second half
give you've got you gotta take chances I
hate that you reminded me of that but
sorry that's okay
well you also wanted one you'll see one
it's not like you were over you know
that a second I know and it's
interesting you know that in Arizona
yesterday I mean Seattle returns to the
spot where they could have had two
instead of one that were they lost
Richard Sherman and camp Chancellor it
looks like they've lost now Earl Thomas
that buildings kind of like a Bermuda
Triangle the way
so what what do you think of Earl Thomas
is exit yesterday I didn't agree with
the way he exited I could've did that a
little better
mhm but I understand his frustration III
know why he did that
I think as an example of why Le'Veon
Bell is out why he's not returning and
it's guys like Earl Thomas who play so
hard every single play risk his body I
mean he's a he's a he's a missile out
there he reminds me of a bob Sanders but
you know old teammate of mine yes sir
you know a smaller guy but I mean he
play big you risk you risk it all at
every play so you guys in the NFL that
just wants some security they just want
some security and I know the outsiders
were say yeah but he's making 10 million
dollars a year you can't look at it like
that you just want some security that if
I'm out playing this contract and I'm
gonna give you everything you know that
I have then I expect you to give the
same thing but why do you think Levien's
teammates the first week it happened
were so outspoken about him not being I
guess they're for the team I don't know
I don't know I don't know why and it was
mainly two offensive linemen III and
also player reps yeah yeah I don't get
it I don't get it but you do understand
you didn't see Antonio Brown saying
anything I didn't hear him say anything
I mean because guys like that did get it
they the guys that's in those type of
situations they get it it
it's a it's a it's a sin rich for you to
talk about another guy's money about
another guy's contract know me you kind
of sit back and you talk to each other
behind closed doors about what's going
on but you never you never go to the
meeting and do that well I mean in
Lebanon said on an Instagram posts
showing that Bobby Wagner said that I'd
be pissed off if I was Earl Thomas he
said that I'll be the bad guy for
everybody his situations a little bit
different though cuz he can't talk
long-term deal he right I mean he said
he's making a point to the Steelers that
you didn't give me what I wanted so I'm
not given what you want which is my
services right now exactly it's a it's a
chess match
it really is it's one of those things
where you see who-who flinches first
obviously it's living on going up
against a big organization you know but
as a former player I nobody touches the
ball per game as much as living I feel
like he's laying it on the line every
single game would you say he should show
up though I mean when you go do you go
show up and didn't say you pull his
hamstring I mean what's the show up and
do what play yeah I mean the team kind
of needs him at one two and one right
now that's what a lot of people are
saying I am of the mindset just
understand this Reggie Wayne here in the
Rich Eisen show that nobody should ever
tell a guy don't get yours when they're
trying to get theirs exactly it's not my
place because I'll tell you what when I
my negotiations are up in my business
I'm trying to get mine trying to get
yours absolutely a thousand percent what
I also don't have the ability to hold
out my services in this business players
do those do some of them can most of
them don't have the leverage levy ons
got some leverage the question is what's
he using the leverage for right now like
what team would want to trade for a guy
that says I'm saving my tire tread for
the long-term relationship I'm having
next I can name quite a few teams that
can use the services I mean one of them
is my former team they can you you don't
think they can use a levy on their coach
absolutely I mean it's a lot of teams
they can use
so he does so much but wouldn't they be
concerned that he's gonna go to the
Colts and and then what and say I don't
really want to try so hard cuz I can't
talk long term contract with you what
that's that's the that's the problem
that he's in and there's no security
there's no way of knowing that he's
gonna want to sign when I'm at the end
of the year so it's again was so so if
you wanted to say that then he really
doesn't have much leverage but I mean as
a former player you feel like hey I'm
gonna I'm gonna risk a lot of money but
I'm gonna make this money up at the end
you know eventually eventually now it's
a it's a gamble I mean if you're talking
about Vegas I mean this is as far as
Vegas you can get I know though yeah but
um Le'Veon is one of those tackle
players he's he's that special Rich
Eisen here our along with Reggie Wayne
on the Rich Eisen show um so let's talk
about Antonio Brown cuz he is just some
talking as well yeah what do you think
that that that 72 hour period where we
saw him very animated on the sidelines
then going back at a former official who
was saying that he's a product of Big
Bend saying trade me we'll find out and
then not showing up for work
what do you translate speak translate
that in from receiver into English I'm
gonna tell you this is as much as a bee
would tell you hey I'm now frustrated he
is totally frustrated he's frustrated in
many aspects he monster was built in
Pittsburgh hey that monster was built
and then all of a sudden you don't feed
that monster he starts to go crazy
one thing about a receiver and I always
Specter look different from a bee
because he was kind of like in my shoes
and when I say that is because I started
off my career I was number three
receiver first round 2001 draft came in
number three then I went to the number
two then I'm eventually moving my way up
to number one so I've had every
different side of that coin you know I
mean mm-hmm
a lot of these guys
they've been number ones their entire
life from Pop Warner high school you
know own up so they just know I want the
ball I'm used to getting the ball I
didn't know how to handle it you know
when they don't get it as a receiver in
NFL one thing you you you don't like oh
I wouldn't say don't like one thing that
strikes a nerve is when another receiver
comes aboard and all of a sudden it
getting all the juice they're getting
all action you like wait a minute I'm
the guy
why are you not throwing me the ball I'm
the guy so that kind of strikes a nerve
so and then when you're not winning when
you win when you're winning you can't
complain because all of a sudden you're
selfish so juju Smith Schuster is the
sort of I guess fly in the ointment
right now juju Smith Shuster is Reggie
Wayne in mm to a B's Marvin Harrison
exactly and is Calvin Ridley right now
the Reggie Wayne to Julio Jones is
Marvin Harris absolutely
it is and listen Marvin Harrison to me
is the best ever
outside of Jerry Rice sure you know okay
you know and there's no knock on those
guys it just happens to go that way
because those guys the Marvin Harris and
the a B's the the Julio Jones they're
gonna get double cover so the Reggie
Wayans of the world we're gonna get
single cover that's not one receiver in
the league that feel like they can be
single cover one-on-one I'm gonna win
that battle I remember my first day in I
met Marvin Harrison I told him I said
hey bro nice to meet you I'm gonna do
everything I can to get this double
coverage off you it just comes that way
and it and slowly but surely it's a
changing of the guard just the way it
goes I mean father time kicks in it
happens it so what's worse Reggie Wayne
having a situation like you mentioned
Julio Jones and Calvin Ridley and
Antonio Brown and you juice with
Schuster not winning during or Odell
Beckham who and not winning where it
seems like there's nobody else who's
getting the ball also and you're not
winning I'm
what's worse is definitely Odell Beckham
jr. I mean because if you want to be you
know a being and jew-jew
like at least you got guys that's
getting this eaten it's just a B that's
the one that's feel like he's not
getting you know he's not being fed even
though just up to last last week he was
top 5 and top 3 actually and targets
Julio Jones I was number one in yards
yeah I mean their situation is a lot
easier yes then obj I mean obj he's in a
situation where he is the guy and he
still can't get the ball the other guys
can get the ball it's it's it's it's a
data in over there what do you think is
happening with the Giants right now
Reggie Wayne I mean you're also well
versed in Manning oh I just think um I
think I just think it's still over there
it's it's a it's a it's a it's some
crawfish without flavor you know I'm a
New Orleans guy so it's Eli exactly but
he's the only cost I know so we are I
guess
ask him the overreaction question that
we had Chris from our number one they
what was the one that you put in there
for for the Giants the actual phrase is
well the actual phrasing for the Giants
is the Giants stuck with Eli Manning too
long overreaction Monday or proper
reaction Monday on that one
Reggie um I think it's over reaction I
mean that's Eli man that's Eli yeah I
mean I would say he's the Titanic you're
gonna go down you know go down with him
but the problem is it's kind of it's
looking more and more like my old
organization Indianapolis there's no
replacement so that the whenever the
departure comes it's gonna end
ugly and it's just like when Peyton was
there and then they bring in Andrew Luck
it wasn't a friendly ending and I think
that's what's gonna happen in New York
Reggie Wayne here on the Rich Eisen show
ask him the poll question here in our
number two of our
week four Monday night yeah Reggie we're
looking at three teams of two losses
losses two and two teams and then the
Steelers which T which of these teams
has the best chance to go on a run
Chargers Cowboys Eagles Seahawks
Steelers ooh
as much as I want to say this otters man
it just can't find a kicker kickers in
charges it just doesn't it doesn't mix
well they still won the game yesterday
won but despite Caleb Sturgis yeah
misfire it's hard
so the kicker is your issue with the
Chargers yeah it's okay I don't know it
must be - it was I don't know just the
charges and kickers it doesn't it
doesn't have not match no I got it I got
a go with a defending Super Bowl champs
I gotta go with the Eagles why do you
say that what a defense this is pretty
good hmm
they just got a hell Sean Jeffrey's back
last week and it's gonna take time to
get Carson Wentz going and instead of
you know the defending champs you got it
you got to beat them you got to beat
them you nobody really wants to go in
Philly and play you know that's a tough
place to play and then the Cowboys I'm
not sold on them Chargers we talked
about the kicker issue
why aren't you sold on the Cowboys it's
not enough Zeke's to go around yeah well
I mean Jerry Jones was saying and he got
a lot of you know tongue-in-cheek grief
certainly from this chair and as well as
everybody else in the NFL community over
the weekend saying that you know they
have an offensive line so do the Rams
they love their quarterback as much as
the Rams loved golf the Rams had Tavon
Austin now the Cowboys have Tavon Austin
they both have really game-changing
running back so the Cowboys aren't too
far away from when the Rams are okay and
you forgot that Jerry's also getting old
he's getting old you start to see things
you may think on paper it looks the same
but on film it's totally different Rams
the best team in the
fell through four weeks you know what I
don't have to say yes oh I would have to
say yes what a what an asterisk when
that is bottom losing to lead on that
second in that secondary yes that kind
of gotta hunt them a little bit welcome
the Vikings certainly lit him up on a
[ __ ] week that is you know cousin it was
a short week it was a short those things
happened then you have Marcus Peters who
wasn't a hundred percent so then who is
the best team to give the Rams problems
is it there is it the Eagles team that's
two and two could it be the Saints what
do you think Packers if believe it or
not I don't know what's going on with
that defense are we expected better with
the sinks but that was my that was my
NFC team before the season started okay
so I'm still gonna ride two sinks I just
drew brees he's like he's amazing he's a
you know shut out the class of 2001
you know he's amazing as long as he got
the ball in his hand they gonna score
points well I said last week when we're
on the subject of briefs here he passes
Peyton Manning I mean four he passes uh
Brett Favre for most completions if he
needs a hundred yards next week to pass
far for second-most yards he needs 200
yards next week to surpass Peyton
Manning for most yards ever he already
has the most 300-yard passing games ever
the most 400 yard passing games ever I
said if he wins another Super Bowl and
gets a league MVP on top of it we have
to we have to discuss Mount Rushmore for
Drew Brees
you know what all-time greats it's it's
it's it's baffling to me that he doesn't
get as much juice as he ever had you
know I mean like he should get more like
you just named off all those tests that
he's yes and nobody seems to even know
that well I think part of that is
everyone assumes it's just a match with
him and Sean Payton you know I mean it's
it's not his fault no I know you know
I'm just I'm just if you're asking why
maybe and I'm not saying that it's it's
rational right it's man I agree with you
and and he may not have to win another
Super Bowl he's gonna have all these
stuff to have all those stats
yeah before her see of my team yes but I
didn't want to bring that up again
before I send you up the 405 to the NFL
Network where you're gonna be on end
game following tonight's Monday night
contest between the Chiefs and the
Broncos what's your favorite Peyton
Manning story
oh my favorite Peyton Manning story -
this is a family show right um okay
that's a good way to start you know you
know it was Peyton's a practical joker
okay he loves to crack jokes but he
never likes to joke on him you know so
he was pulling jokes on one of our you
know equipment guys and just kept
messing with him and messing with him
and messing with him and then all of a
sudden we had practice and you know
practices roughly two hours and some
change we all get out of practice and
get ready to go home take showers you
ready to go home and he goes out to his
car this whole car saran-wrapped it's
fully saran-wrapped and he didn't know
who did it he was I mean he was red I
mean just thinking that big head it was
red right and nobody was saying who it
was nobody whatever wouldn't they
wouldn't telling each other no snitching
allowed right Peyton Manning does what
Peyton Manning do which is he called up
a dealership and had them come take the
saran wrap off he didn't put his hands
on it he made a dealership come to it so
that's that's exactly but did he ever
find out it was the equipment manager
I'll never tell but did you just tell
them no I didn't you said it Reggie
Wayne everybody who do you think wins
tonight you like my homes tonight in the
road start I like never you do I like
them why I think this is the game that
patching my home struggle it's gonna
breathe this it's it's a brick wall
somewhere now did its you're saying it's
some obviously won't be 16 you know it
won't be six
you know it's gonna be a rough patch in
there okay hey I had a hot take Tuesday
last week what was that my heart ached
Tuesday yeah a little far-fetched but
was it patching my home storm for picks
for in this game in this game that's a
hot take that's hot take Tuesday to look
for four I mean that's it's such a hot
take it's still hot six days later yeah
okay very good Reggie Wayne I'd love
that you're part of the NFL Network I
love what you're what you're what you've
been doing I'm survivor
please come back here as much as you
possibly can
are you on the Thursday night coverage
Colts Patriots as well no I'm not okay
I'll be sitting back watching okay
that'll be the week five kickoff I can't
believe we're that deep into the season
Reggie Wayne underscore 17 on Twitter
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience